bonsoir
je
intéressant j'espère que
oubliez ce que je vais vous raconter
alors
il ya presque trois ans je terminais mes
études d'ingénieur à l'école
polytechnique de montréal où j'ai essayé
de fabriquer les matériaux de demain à
partir de plantes et j'ai suivi tous les
courts possibles et imaginables sur les
problématiques environnementales
justement et puis les enjeux
scientifiques et techniques qui sont
associés et ça c'est moi à l'an dernier
je suis en train d'accrocher l'enseigne
du café que j'allais inauguré le soir
même au centre ville de toulouse
pourriez me dire quel est le lien ça
pourrait vous surprendre mais ce qui m'a
amené à cet endroit c'est vraiment les
mêmes idées que celles que j'ai cultivé
au canada est la question que j'aimerais
explorer avec vous ce soir c'est
qu'est-ce qu'une si petit nice petites
initiatives que ouvrir un café peut bien
avoir affaire avec des enjeux aussi
importants quel impact ça pourrait bien
avoir alors pour parler de ça ce soir
j'ai besoin de partager avec vous
quelques constats autour des sciences et
de comment elles sont perçus aujourd'hui
par le public la première chose qu'on
peut se dire c'est que j'espère qu'ils
apprécient la qualité des dessins j'ai
mis tout mon coeur aujourd'hui les
sciences avance à un rythme accéléré de
plus en plus rapide si on veut devenir
un spécialiste dans un domaine ça te
prend de plus en plus de temps de
ressources on se spécialise et au final
c'est à mettre en regard avec un certain
écart qui se creuse avec les
connaissances du grand public quand on
est un citoyen ou une citoyenne lambda
on est de plus en plus éloignés de la
pointe de la recherche dans de nombreux
domaines
et ça c'est un peu préoccupant à
l'époque où finalement ces enjeux
scientifiques et techniques ils ont un
rôle prépondérant pour beaucoup d'enjeux
auxquels on fait face en tant que
société on peut penser au changement
climatique aux questions liées à
l'énergie on peut penser aux enjeux
éthiques autour de la biologie j'ai pas
mentionné de nos technologies tiens je
peux le faire on peut penser à
l'intelligence artificielle aubier
humains qui se perpétue à travers des
algorithmes il ya beaucoup de choses
qu'on pourrait mentionner et mon opinion
c'est que pour beaucoup de ces enjeux on
n'a pas tant besoin de nouvelles
technologies
mais surtout de citoyens qu'ils sont
bien informés avec un esprit critique
affûté qui peuvent passer à l'action
avec les bonnes informations en
la deuxième chose c'est que
malheureusement aujourd'hui pour
beaucoup de gens il ya une certaine
méfiance envers les sciences qui se
développent les sciences nous la science
peuvent être un peu raccrocher à quelque
chose de rigide de froid d'imposer qui
vient d'en haut c'est élitiste
parfois il ya des intérêts économiques
cacher des fois ses fantasmes et
d'autres fois c'est des craintes bien
légitime mais quoi qu'il en soit ce
qu'il faut retenir c'est que pour
beaucoup de gens c'est de plus en plus
difficile de savoir en qui on va
accorder sa confiance
voir si on va accorder sa confiance à
quelqu'un tout court sur ces sujets et
puis pour glacer le gâteau parce que
sinon ce n'était pas assez bien déjà il
ya le problème des bulles d'opinion
numérique
donc ça on a tous fait plus ou moins
l'expérience on est dans une sphère de
gens qui pensent plus ou moins comme
nous en ligne et puis on se retrouve
dans une logique d'une ou versus e sur
beaucoup de sujets on est en police
arial 12 dans l'espace de commentaires
sont ils des trucs pas possibles et ça
laisse très peu d espace à la nuance
entre deux eaux sujets qui ont de
nombreuses facettes spoiler tous les
sujets ont de nombreuses facettes donc
c'est compliqué et d'autant plus en
sciences du coup c'est vraiment très
compliqué d'avoir des débats autour de
ça j'ajoute à ça qu'on n'a jamais eu
autant besoin d'éducation à l'esprit
critique quand on voit la vitesse à
laquelle peuvent se diffuser des idées
fausses si elles ont fait vibrer la
bonne corde émotionnelle où les bons
idéaux personnel qu'on peut avoir
et attention je ne suis pas en train de
dire qu'il ya un groupe de gens qui est
stupide et qui est n'importe quoi et
puis des gens ils font attention literie
et où on est tous dans ce cas là quelque
part en créant des mécanismes auxquels
il faut faire très attention
heureusement ce tableau bien négatif est
contrebalancé par un grand renouveau de
la médiation scientifique aujourd'hui
nous on a beaucoup de chance j'ai mis
youtube direct avec le petit logo parce
que en france on a beaucoup beaucoup de
chaînes youtube avec plein de gens qui
ont des trucs incroyables sur plein de
domaines pour quelqu'un qui est curieux
c'est vraiment une grande chance qu'on
appuie je parle même pas des chaînes
anglophone on a aussi des podcasts audio
qui se développent et puis on a même des
festivals un peu partout en france qui
se développe autour est la
caractéristique compte tous ces nouveaux
acteurs on pourrait dire en commun c'est
qu'ils arrivent à parler de séance de
manière humoristique un peu décalé avec
un certain un certain ton informel c'est
convivial et ça s'est vraiment bien
puisqu'au final quand on passe un bon
moment et qu'on rigole un bon coup c'est
quand même le meilleur moyen qu'on a
pour revisiter les a priori qu'on a sur
un sujet voire même donné envie d'en
savoir plus alors deux bémols cela dit
déjà le contenu cas en ligne la plupart
du temps on va le consommer seul on va
peut-être le partager avec des gens où
ils ont discuté de temps à autre mais
c'est vrai que la majorité dedans on est
seul avec ça et puis les festivals qui
ont lieu
c'est un endroit un moment si on peut y
aller ça reste limité dans le temps
alors si on parle de diffuser la science
vaut bien sûr remercié tous les acteurs
conventionnel qui ya les bibliothèques
les musées les centres de culture
scientifique
tout ça c'est autant d'acteurs qui sont
déjà présents là tout au long de l'année
pour rendre la science accessible à tous
mais rien n'étant parfait
ces institutions peuvent souffrir d'un
certain handicap qu'elles ont qui est
l'image qu'elles ont auprès du public
je m'explique même avec les personnes
les plus maudit motiver les idées les
plus efficaces et il faut le dire c'est
un peu difficile si on manque de moyens
dans le service public
il peut être très difficile de se battre
contre le fait que le mot musée où le
mot bibliothèque harry avec tout un
florilège de clichés d'idées reçues
et finalement ça va rendre la tâche très
difficile ces institutions là pour
arriver à sensibiliser des gens qui ne
sont pas intéressés par ce sujet au
départ encore moins quelqu'un qui a un
mauvais a priori envers sa typiquement
pour les sciences un mauvais souvenirs
scolaires par exemple alors toutes ces
réflexions je les ai eu qu un ami
d'enfance qui était devenu biologiste
lui et on se retrouver tous les deux à
se dire on veut s'investir dans la
diffusion des sciences au grand public
faire quelque chose là dedans parce
qu'on pense que c'est important on veut
faire quelque chose pour cette histoire
de méfiance envers les sciences de
polarisation des discussions et puis
nous ce qui nous semble plus simple
c'est d'injecter du bien social quoi du
vrai dialogue entre
autour de ça et on voit tous ces
nouveaux acteurs qui arrivent à avoir un
côté cool mais bon voilà c'est limité ou
alors c'est du contenu en ligne
et puis il ya les acteurs conventionnel
mais du fait de leur nature
institutionnelle
ils ont un certain handicap d'avoir le
côté décontracté que peuvent avoir les
autres donc comment on trouve notre
antre de notre briques complémentaires
qu'on peut apporter à l'édifice
alors il faut bien commencer quelque
part comment on fait un lieu physique
qui attire par défaut un large public et
on peut parler d'un truc de manière
conviviale
bon je voulais griller dans l'intro du
coup vous voyez où je veux en venir
dans la culture française et a pas
trente mille c'est un café ok faisons un
café pour la diffusion des sciences
c'est logique
ok mais attention je vous parle pas d'un
café où on fait juste une conférence de
temps à autre je vous parle d'un lieu
qui est vraiment conçu et pensé de a à z
autour de ça alors ça ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'il faut qu'on puisse
parler de science de manière rigoureuse
et conviviale ça veut dire qu'il faut
qu'on puisse prendre le temps d'examiner
ses propres idées ses propres opinions
celle des autres avoir des discussions
constructives autour de ça et puis qui
est quelque chose pour titiller la
curiosité des gens pour sensibiliser
ceux qui au départ s'en fiche
complètement de ces sujets là point
bonus c'est un café donc il faut payer
le loyer
donc il faut trouver un modèle
économique qui est assez efficace tout
en restant accessible pour le public
alors un café pour parler des sciences
spine d incroyablement neuf donc le
premier réflexe qu'on a eu c'est où
est-ce que ça a été fait qu'il a fait
avant nous et où sous quelle forme et on
a été très étonné de pas vraiment trouvé
alors il existe des cafés ou parle de
science de temps à autre ou des bars il
ya des lieux culturels où il ya un petit
côté salon etc
mais un café vraiment installé conçu de
a à z pour la diffusion des sciences on
n'a pas vraiment trouvé donc en a créé
on a créé le premier café scientifique
de france + a claqué on était content tu
es donc je vais partager avec vous notre
petite recette pour de la culture
scientifique conviviale alors c'est ni
la seule ni la meilleure mais on en est
très satisfait alors la première chose
premier ingrédient c'est qu'il faut un
an pour bien mener la chose
et nous on est convaincus qu'ils font un
nom qui soit sans lien évident avec les
sciences parce que si vous mettez à la
croisée des sciences dans la rue où
passe devant on voit science en fait
c'est pas pour moi
et donc voilà on fait de l'entre- soir
on n'arrive pas à sensibiliser les gens
qui se sentent pas proches de ces sujets
au départ donc dans notre cas eureka
fait un petit jeu de mots un clin d'oeil
avec archimède mais pas plus
la deuxième chose c'est qu'il faut que
le lieu soit une invitation
donc ça veut dire que dans les objets
qu'il ya dans la décoration il ya des
microscopes il ya une fourmilière
il ya des jeux il ya un simulateur de
vol on à toulouse quand même il ya des
bouquins il ya des bd sur tous les
domaines pour tous les âges l'idée c'est
vraiment que il ya des invitations tous
tout ça c'est autant de petites portes
ouvertes à aller creuser des des sujets
autour des sciences mais attention ça
reste vraiment une invitation ne
l'imposent pas quelqu'un peut très bien
venir jouer discuter faire quelque chose
et puis repartir sans avoir vu le début
du mot science l'idée c'est vraiment
d'avoir quelque chose qui est passif et
qui est là pour donner envie finalement
chez nous il ya beaucoup plus de
ressources qui donne envie d'aller
ailleurs une bibliothèque une vidéo
youtube que sais-je
plutôt que de plonger vraiment au coeur
d'un sujet la chose suivante c'est qu'il
faut absolument valoriser la prise de
parole c'est très important que dans la
journée quand nous on va discuter avec
les gens qu'on soit disponible pour
discuter avec les gens ou même quand on
va faire des événements et que on va
avoir des interactions et des
intervenants il faut mettre en avant au
maximum le partage la prise de parole le
fait de pouvoir dire ce qu'on pense et
d'écouter les autres et d'échangés
autour de tout ça et pas d'être dans un
quelque chose ou typiquement la wii vous
m'écoutez je suis en train de parler
donc c'est très important de faire
attention à ça pour qu'on puisse avancer
que chacun puisse
avancez dans ses pensées le point
suivant est un peu moins drôle mais il
est très important quand on parle de
science c'est la rigueur ça veut dire
que dans nos liens une recherche
personnelle pardon qu'on va faire avant
de faire quelque chose ou dans les liens
qu'on développe avec les chercheurs et
les chercheuses qu'on invite des labos
pour venir parler au public
on est toujours rigoureux on essaye
d'être au plus proche du sujet de faire
attention à ce qu'on raconte
et là vous pourriez vous dire rigoureux
et conviviale c'est quand même un
mariage un peu compliqué dans le final
on était très contents d'observer que
non le simple le cadre qu'on avait créé
l'ambiance qu'on avait créé suffit a
vraiment créé une très bonne entente
entre les membres du public ou entre le
public et les intervenants et au final
on peut très bien fait un truc rigoureux
et sérieux et convivial et on se marre
bien et dernier point là pas d'image
parce que je peux pas l'image et se s il
va falloir me croire sur parole il faut
qu'on s'y sente bien pourquoi mais nous
on est convaincu que si on veut pouvoir
examiner ses propres idées ses propres
opinions
discutez celle des autres avoir un
échange constructif autour de tout ça il
faut que chacun se sente à l'aise bien
qu'on soit pas sur nos gardes sinon ça
peut virer au dialogue de sourds très
vite sur des sujets où un peu passionnel
et donc nous on la traduit de la manière
la plus basique qui soit c'est il faut
qu'on se sente à la maison donc ça à
plusieurs ramifications
ça veut dire que déjà dans la manière
dont le lieu est décoré agences et il
faut que ça respire ça ça veut dire que
on peut y aller quand on veut donc les
horaires soit le plus large possible
et puis ça veut dire aussi que quand on
est chez soi on peut faire un peu ce
qu'on veut on peut prendre ce qu'on veut
sans demander à personne donc y ait une
forme de libre service très bien et donc
voilà tous les ingrédients qu'on a
utilisées pour donner vie à notre idée
est le résultat c'est eureka fait le
café des curiosités
ouvert sept jours sur sept de 10 heures
à 22 heures et vous pouvez venir
utiliser ce que vous voulez consommer ce
que voulait tout est inventé en libre
service
là vous me regardez en dix ans yes il ya
un problème comment ça tient debout
cette histoire donc nous le modèle qu'on
a choisi c'est d'avoir un tarif qui au
temps passé la journée et une entrée
fixe le soir bien sûr notre bébé
le second sera jamais aussi accessible
qu'un service public mais on essaye de
faire le maximum de pas dans cette
direction alors le projet relativement
jeune on a fêté la première année le
mois dernier mais on a déjà une montagne
de retour positif et beaucoup de raisons
de penser qu'on est dans la bonne
direction sur la bonne voie il me serait
très difficile de vous expliquer tout ce
qui s'y passe parce qu'on a fait plus de
160 événement sur la première année donc
ça fait presque un tous les deux jours
et je ne pourrai pas vous détailler
toute la diversité mais je vais quand
même vous raconter un exemple qui pour
moi résume plutôt bien le potentiel que
peut avoir cette approche de la culture
scientifique convivial en mars dernier
avec deux associations étudiantes
désolé c'était à paul sabatier on a
organisé une conférence débat autour du
glyphosate
alors s'il ya bien un sujet scientifique
où il faut faire attention à ce qu'on
dit où il ya des passions qui peuvent se
déchaîner
et il ya des enjeux sociaux qui entoure
tout ça c'est celui-là donc vous faire
attention
en plus des deux intervenants qui
étaient mobilisés par les associations
qui était de professeur en lycée
agricole on a contacté l'institut
national de la recherche agronomique
donc l'inra grâce à qui deux chercheurs
sont venus en qualité de garant juste
pour apporter leur expertise puissent
qu'ils étaient proches du sujet et
éviter que quelqu'un dise quelque chose
complètement éloigné de la réalité sans
avoir de contrepoids finalement alors on
a un petit peu stressé avant et au final
on a été merveilleusement bien surpris
puisque tout s'est très bien passé on a
eu une super conference on a eu un débat
mouvant où le public pouvait se
positionner physiquement dans la salle
et donner son avis qui était animé avec
brio par les étudiants d'ailleurs et au
final même s'il y avait beaucoup de gens
dans la salle qui avaient des opinions
divergentes
c'est un euphémisme croyez moi sur
beaucoup de points là l'ambiance du lieu
et la manière dont la parole de chacun
étaient respectées a vraiment permis de
garder une bonne cohésion une bonne
entente et d'avoir des échanges
constructifs
à tel point que la responsable de
communication de l'inra m'a dit en
partant et c'est une personne qui a vu
beaucoup
débats et de sujets sur de discussions
sur ce sujet par dont elle m'a dit en
partant que la qualité des discussions
qu'elle avait observée était bien
meilleure que dans d'autres cadres plus
sérieux on pourrait dire qu'un café
voire même entre certains scientifiques
ce qu'elle a vu avant alors voilà une
des nombreuses raisons qui fait qu'on
pense qu'on est dans la bonne direction
et c'est cette direction que j'aimerais
vous laisser avant qu'on rentre tous
chez soi ce soir ou qu'on a discuté
c'est que aujourd'hui on vit dans un
monde complexe où les sciences et les
technologies ont un rôle prépondérant à
jouer dans les enjeux auxquels on fait
face en tant que société pour faire face
à ces enjeux justement il faut être
nombreux
il faut être bien informé avoir un
esprit critique affûté une culture de la
nuance et dans une certaine mesure faut
qu'on s'entende bien pour coopérer et
c'est pour toutes ces raisons que je
pense que des initiatives comme la nôtre
aussi petite soit elle peut vraiment
avoir un immense impact sur ces
questions je pense que créer du lien
social dans des endroits qui sont à
taille humaine où on peut partager la
culture scientifique de manière
conviviale et collective
c'est vraiment une direction dans
laquelle il faut s'engouffrer
si vous n'êtes pas d'accord je vous
invite au 24 rue gambetta à toulouse
vous offre un café et en discute
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]